next game in what hei the R
kamamarena
Spain so then we'll
probably get Mar
setup here so let's see which variant
black
is missing looks like the classic
variant plays B6 you can also
do that B7 the Wariante has some tricks
Tower C1 e.g. is now bad because
Knight D4 bishop D4 bishop H6
strange trick E4 hangs then queen D2
is not good either because of knight D4
bishop4 E5 I always play knight
bad
C6 I've already won a few good games with it
in long chess that's now becoming a thing
again aha he immediately plays interestingly well on d5
um cded E5 I could react and
then
F4 yes I'll start with that two that
probably belongs here anyway
so
I can't imagine that I
have any big alternatives to that
so the question now is F6 what kind of
move is that okay does
n't matter if  I now make rook D1 hangs
the 5 several times probably knight
E4 answers I could then
swap there maybe the other
rook
too yes the zin could be valuable again on the zin
especially if I
swap here now so rook C1 that's
exactly why we now have one
But I think the endgame
should be a little bit better for I know I have a
chance to maybe pick up the E4 pawn
or at least put it under pressure
and the move B6 is so
unpleasant that he made it in
the structure where the pawn would be on B7
There's probably nothing
going on here at all now, but something
stupid has to be taken care of here.
Runner A6 can, unfortunately, Runner B7 can
answer
tactically, but he can't,
he can't, and um, he won't win the
material, so now we want to
think again, of course  Tower C7 wins the
quality but still bishop B7 tower B7 tower
C8 tower C8 tower C8 bishop
F8
F5 typical
motif drotrunner
H6 I don't see at the moment how he
prevents that, it's probably even
stronger I mean h man if it doesn't
work it's stupid because  Of course the jellyfish would have
won too, so Bishop
H6 is also checkmate at the same time, so
to speak, when it
comes
I don't see any
move so okay, I can just
take it and now
Bishop F6 should actually win Bishop F6
King G8 E6 threatens E7 he can
exchange once threatens  still E7 yes
check res that was a little faster than
taking the jellyfish but it is an
important important motif when the
rook comes to the back row then
bishop H6 may have prevented some
problems with time here